should you allow a referendum well let's
let's wait and see what uh actually
happens but
i think that most people in uh in
scotland most people around the whole of
the uk
feel that this is not the time as we're
coming forwards
out of a a pandemic together this is not
the time
to have a a reckless and i think
irresponsible
uh second referendum we had one only a
few
years ago i think what most people want
is to focus on
the country and taking it forward and
and rebuilding
our economy getting people into work
that seems to me
to be the priority for the country there
are reports that two members of the
india g7 delegation have tested
positives for covid
uh was it a mistake to hold this meeting
in person
especially with the the new variant
that's out there
i think it's very important to try to to
continue as much business as you
as you can as a government uh we have a
very important relationship with india
with our
our g7 partners as i understand it
what's happened is that the
the individuals concerned are all uh
they're all isolating
uh now and uh when i see i will be
seeing the indian
foreign minister later on this afternoon
but that will be a
zoom exchange i'm given to understand